autres dossiers brûlants sur la scène
internationale celui de l'ukraine kiev
cran toujours une invasion russe à sa
frontière est depuis des jours
maintenant les négociations vont bon
train pour tenter de calmer les ardeurs
de moscou ce vendredi c'est le président
emmanuel macron qui s'est entretenu avec
vladimir poutine rompant ainsi le tête à
tête au russo américain on en parle avec
vos bruno daroux bonjour bonjour
d'horreur rebonjour le président
emmanuel macron qui a donc enfilé on le
sait il ya quelques jours son costume de
président de l'union européenne il s'est
donc imposé dans ces négociations
il faut à tout prix faire entendre la
voix de l'europe il faut à tout prix
faire entendre la voix de l'europe
absolument il faut aussi faire au
passage entendre la voix de la france
c'est pas mal aussi à deux mois et demi
maintenant du premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle ça permet emmanuel macron
de se situer un peu en surplomb par
rapport aux autres candidats
ce qui est quand même à noter c'est
qu'effectivement un vladimir poutine a
accepté de dialoguer avec l'un des
dirigeants européens qui représente donc
pour six mois l'union européenne on sait
que la lumière poutine avait expliqué
ils sont ministres des affaires
étrangères sergueï lavrov également que
finalement mieux valait discuter
directement avec les états unis qui
était en quelque sorte les patrons
diplomatique de l'europe donc autant
parler à ceux qui étaient les donneurs
d'ordre en quelque sorte là visiblement
il ya un petit changement difficile de
savoir si c'est parce que les russes
manie le chaud et le froid après avoir
question une position assez dur ils
disent maintenant qu'ils n'ont pas
l'intention d'attaquer l'ukraine qu'il
souhaite simplement que les occidentaux
prennent en compte leur inquiétude c'est
ce qu'a dit vladimir poutine qui estime
que ce n'est pas le cas jusqu'à présent
et qui donc il n'est pas satisfait mais
le ton est plus conciliant et comme le
temps est plus conciliant là à ce moment
là de la phase de cette phase
diplomatique
eh bien on peut parler aux européens
puisqu'ils veulent jouer les médiateurs
on va on va voir si ça peut ça peut
marcher du point de vue russe qui t'a
dit viser un peu le camp occidental
peut-être toujours est il qu'ils
acceptent de prendre parole
avec les européens emmanuel macron lui
il a enfilé vous l'aviez le costume de
président du conseil de l'union
européenne et aussi de pays garant que
ce sont des accords de minsk et c'est
sur cet aspect là que la france veut
avancer
faire en sorte que les ukrainiens et les
russes arrivent à mettre en oeuvre
réellement ces accords de minsk qui ont
donc été signée il ya un peu plus de six
ans maintenant et permet enfin de régler
déjà la situation du don de base ce qui
espère-t-on à paris peut-être pourrait
permettre dans moins de rire les
tensions à la frontière regarde bien
merci bruno daroux pour ses explications
et donc cet aspect diplomatique